[whistle blowing]
What she's managing now is superhuman.
She would have lost her manual dexterity.
Hi, my name's John Hudson.
I'm the UK Military's
chief survival instructor,
land or sea, Arctic, desert or jungle.
And I train the trainers how to teach that
to everyone else in the UK Military.
Today, we're going to be looking at
ocean-survival scenes in movies,
and we're going to be
judging how real they are.
That looks to me like
they're diving vertically
at the sea, and nobody will survive.
It would be like hitting concrete.
What tends to happen in airplane ditchings
is you're just trying to do a
controlled landing on water,
like Sully did, like Tom
Hanks does, on the Hudson.
The water's gonna flush backwards.
The best place for Tom
Hanks, or any of us, to sit
in that sort of scenario
is probably near an over-wing exit.
Definitely be near an exit.
If you take cold water,
you can only hold your breath
for about five or 10 seconds.
And the lethal dose for
salt water is 1 1/2 liters.
So if you're in an airplane
and you're not near the exit,
and it fills with --
or a helicopter --
and it fills with cold
water, and you go [gasps],
you're going to die, because you've taken
the lethal dose of salt
water into your lungs.
Have a feel.
You check next time you're on an airplane.
When they say, "Your life
preserver is under your seat,"
have a look around and
see if anyone checks.
I always do.
Remember, in a sinking airplane, though,
do not inflate it until you're outside.
Because as it sinks, you'll be
trapped inside the fuselage.
Another bit of Hollywoodism,
because all of these life
rafts have a weak link on them.
So if there's any strain like
this put on the life raft,
the cord will tear away
without ripping the life raft,
so that if it's attached
to a sinking airplane
and the airplane sinks, you
don't get dragged down with it.
It's built in. It's a
clever design feature.
He can hold his breath
because he's in the tropics.
But it's at night and it's in
a storm, so in all likelihood,
the air temperature and everything else,
gonna be a bit cold.
It will churn the sea up a little bit.
You'll get that mixing.
So it won't be warm water that he's in.
It still is gonna limit how
long he can hold his breath for.
It's a little bit of Hollywood
going on, I think, this bit.
[turbine spinning]
In that kind of storm,
is the fuel likely to have caught fire?
Probably not.
But it makes for a good scene, doesn't it?
It looks cool.
The airplane's landed with such force
that it smashed apart and caught fire.
And yet, we've still got an engine,
which weighs several
tons, above the water.
So, we're kind of playing
with time and reality
for a brilliant scene here.
It's only gonna get 4
out of 10 for realism.
Is there anyone alive out there?
This is people from the Carpathia
coming to try and find
survivors from the Titanic.
What signs of life
you'll be able to detect,
maybe a ripple or some small movement.
But by this point, people
are going to be unconscious.
There's no way you can survive
in water that temperature
for even more than an hour.
You know, half of us will
be dead within 45 minutes.
So the only people who would have survived
were those who were
floating on or in something,
rather than the water itself.
[whimpering]
You can see the ice in her
hair. That's realistic.
When we do ice-breaking drills
in the Arctic with our guys,
soon as you get out of the frozen lake,
your hair is like glass straightaway.
But, if you both wanted to survive,
your best chance is to
both try and get on.
It'll be a little bit wobbly,
but you're gonna lie still.
And we know the sea was
super calm that night,
so you've got a good
chance of getting on there.
If you can get the big
arteries away from the water,
like your femoral arteries
or under your armpits
and round your neck,
you'll survive for longer.
Come back.
Come back! Come back!
What could she do to raise his attention
while she's actually on there?
Maybe she's got something
she can clank together
to raise a metallic noise
that would carry a long way.
That point there, where
she jumps into the water,
what happens to humans on
immersion in cold water
is that you have an absolutely
uncontrolled gasp response.
Absolutely uncontrollable.
So, the main problem with Hollywood films
about cold-water survival
is that they never gasp
and they never hyperventilate
for about a minute afterwards.
And it's absolutely uncontrollable.
She probably wouldn't
have been able to swim
initially, at first.
We've tested Olympic athletes
at the Institute of Naval Medicine
on how people respond to this,
and gold and silver
medalists can't do this.
[man yelling]
[whistle blowing]
What she's managing now is superhuman.
She would have lost her manual dexterity.
Absolutely no chance of
being able to do that
when you're that cold.
This is the Inuit sign for greeting,
proving that you've got manual dexterity.
Which is why, grimly, in
the bottom of a life raft,
you often find human teeth,
because it's impossible to open packets.
People try to rip them
out with fists and teeth.
So, to adjust a small
whistle into your lips,
when it's gonna be frozen
to that guy's lips anyway,
and then stick it in your
own mouth, super unlikely.
That's why in modern life rafts
we're given plastic whistles,
because they are not as
prone to those problems.
When we get to the specifics
about survival and rescue,
eh,
2 out of 10.
I know of one person from Iceland
who survived conditions like
this, and that's a miracle.
Mac,
two or three sips a day, yeah?
We've got to make it last.
If you're not in control
of your situation,
you've got to try and find
something that you can control.
And that's generating a
small routine of tasks.
Heliographs are a brilliant survival item.
Packed in most military survival kits.
Each little reflective square,
each inch of reflectivity
will project the sun back about 10 miles.
So a 2-inch square like
that's good for 20 miles,
which for the size and
weight of it's phenomenal.
This is a pretty accurate view
of what people look
like after they've baked
in the sun in a life raft for a while.
And what you can do to
try and prevent that
is use anything for shade.
So, commonly, people will
take their shirts off
and use it as a shade shelter.
All life rafts these days have
got shade shelters on them.
You're gonna get blistered and burned.
What people have actually tried to do,
if they've got no medicine
supplies with them,
is any grease they can find.
There was a guy in the
Second World War who,
in his post-action report,
described using his finger
and any little bit of grease,
like maybe behind his
ear, trying to use that
to parched lips that crack and bleed.
[bird squawking]
People will catch sea birds in life rafts
and try to eat them.
One of the best things
to pack as survival food
is a can of dog or cat food,
because you'll only eat it
if you're really hungry.
Same with an albatross.
What people try to do to
make it more palatable
is normally to dry it.
So if they've got any kind of thin lines,
they can dry it in the sun,
so you get a kind of seabird jerky.
I don't think I can do it.
We've got to try.
[retching]
Only eat it if you think
it won't make you sick.
If you're ill and you're sick,
you lose the calories you've
actually got in your stomach,
and the fluid that's with
it, which is worse for you.
But the problem with
foods like that, proteins,
is it takes fresh water to digest.
And the bigger problem that survivors
have at sea is water acquisition,
because you need water far
sooner than you need food.
We can survive for weeks without eating,
but you can't survive more
than a few hours or days
in scorching sun without water.
So if you eat protein,
it'll exacerbate the not-drinking part,
which is one of their major problems.
If you haven't got loads of water,
don't eat the albatross.
It's long enough for you
to try and grab the tail
away from the bitey end.
What you can do, you know,
he's giving it a good shearing.
What you can do with sharks,
if you catch a small enough
one, is turn it upside down.
When you flip them upside down,
they go into a tonic state,
which means they're sort
of, "Oh, what's happening?"
I'd give this one 10 out of 10.
This is the scenario that
we train our aircrew for,
surviving in a life raft at sea
where the life raft is something
that's packed along with
the aircraft survival kit.
They are far more at risk
from us than we are from them.
But great whites specifically
are very unlikely to
take mammals from rocks.
You see orcas do it.
Killer whales will do it.
But, you know, great white
sharks, it's unlikely.
What they're trying to
do is just get easy meat.
If you're on a rock, you're not easy food.
Can you outswim a shark?
No. [laughs]
Should you try? No.
When sharks attack, there's
not a lot you can do about it.
If you're in a group, if you're huddled,
try and stay together.
Don't start smashing the water
or doing any violent movements,
'cause that'll attract them.
You want to be unattractive to this thing.
You want to look and feel
like something it's not used to eating.
It all depends on what kind of jellyfish,
and goodness knows what
they're supposed to be.
But some of them are lethally
dangerous, aren't they?
You swim into jellyfish,
the shark's definitely
gonna have a munch at you.
Even if it's just an exploratory bite
'cause you're bleeding,
that could be enough to sever an artery,
and then you'll bleed out.
Sharkskin's incredibly thick.
The thinnest part is on the nose.
So if you did have the
choice, which you won't have,
and you did have a weapon,
which you probably won't have,
and you were gonna have a go, then, yeah,
go for it around the nose.
Entertainment rating, oh,
I don't know, 7 out of 10.
Realism rating, maybe a 2.
Where's the beach?
Frank, wake up!
It's not uncommon for people to drift
that out of range of
getting back into land.
It's a really common way for people
to get into difficulties.
One of the first senses you lose
in a survival situation
is your sense of humor.
And you know that in your mates.
If they've ever had a
real crisis in their life
and it's not right to joke about it,
they won't joke about it.
In a life raft, what
you can do is take five.
Now, really difficult if you're two people
in a one-person raft.
But if it's any other sort of scenario,
either shut up for five
minutes or just take a break.
You know, just take that time out.
Frank: It should've been you!
Mac: No!
Luckily, life-raft knives
have got a blunted end,
and they float,
'cause that's the next
thing that would happen.
Are you talking about
killing and eating me, Frank?
Maybe I am, maybe I ain't, rum ham.
Certainly, in the accounts
that I've come across
from British mariners,
if you're in a life raft
and it's all getting a bit difficult
and everyone's really, really hungry,
then one of you is gonna get eaten.
They used to draw lots in
life rafts back in the day,
like 1700s and so, even up until then.
Normally, it was the young cabin boy
that got knocked on the head,
so all the old sweats have
probably rigged the draw.
But, yeah, they'd draw lots.
You don't need to eat that urgently.
We can survive for weeks without food.
So, yeah, cannibalism,
not that high on the list.
All I'm saying is that when
you go into survival mode,
it's every man for himself.
What is survival mode? I don't know.
I know it's not every man for himself.
It's everyone together.
Realism, 10 out of 10.
That's how people that
haven't thought about it
and haven't been trained
will probably react.
No, no, no!
So, by trying to free the mast
that was bashing into
the side of the boat,
she's unfortunately got
tangled up in the sail
that's now dragging her down.
One of the things we teach pilots to do
is get away from their parachute,
'cause it'll do exactly the same.
But you can actually breathe through them.
So, there's a little air pocket,
so she did the right thing there.
Looking good, mama.
Duct tape's amazing, isn't it?
You can fix most things with it.
It's commonly put in survival packs.
You've got to test somewhere first.
You've got to make sure
it's clean and dry.
Difficult at sea, but it's a calm day.
'Cause if there's any moisture,
that'll affect the adhesive.
So, the first thing to
do is protect yourself
from the hazards, which she's done.
The next thing she needs
to do is get rescued,
be located, as we call
it in military survival.
So she's going right the
way through it logically,
and she's doing exactly the right things,
try to get rescued.
And then later, when she's
got some kind of message
for help out there, then, yeah,
I'll worry about water and food.
What we'll tend to do
is throw a line to them,
if they're compos mentis.
But if they're unconscious or if they're
further away than we can throw the line,
then we'll tie it around someone's middle,
just like she's done.
So, what she's doing
is absolutely the same as
we would teach people to do.
She hasn't got a life preserver on
is the one thing I'd
pick her up for on that.
[groaning]
Pulling someone out of the
water is really hard work.
If they've got a buoyancy aid on,
what you can do is sort of
almost semi-submerse the body,
and then the buoyancy
will give you a kick up.
But with a high-sided vessel
or relatively high-sided vessel like that,
it's really tricky.
And the other problem with
getting people out of the water,
not a lot of folk know
about hydrostatic squeeze
and post-rescue collapse.
Prioritizing her survival options,
protection, location, water, and food,
that gets a 10 out of 10.
[yelling]
So, what can you do in this
situation if you're these guys?
If there's a massive wave like that
coming straight at the boat,
there's not a lot they can do.
The reason he's accelerating is like
when you're trying to
paddle out through a big set
when you're surfing, you
try and go a bit faster
to get beyond it before it breaks.
And that's about all they can do.
But it's wrong place, wrong time.
You can't turn a boat round fast enough
if the wave's coming that quick.
If you get caught sideways on it,
it's going to tumble and destroy it.
You could try and outrun it,
but that boat isn't built for speed.
What could you do?
Emergency position-indicator beacons
that will broadcast a
satellite where you are,
have one of those on your person,
have a survival suit,
have a life preserver.
And if the boat becomes untenable
because the sea's just too big,
if you look at the top of the bridge house
on the fishing boat,
that white canister is a life raft.
Even when the crib is going off,
when it's really big,
it's nothing like that.
They do happen, though.
There's varying theories
as to what creates them.
Mostly it's down around
the South Africa region.
There's an Antarctic
current that comes up,
meets the warmer water,
and creates this kind of enormous pitching
that cuts broken ships
in half, in the past.
This is a 10 out of 10.
There's a seafarers'
institute for a reason,
to look after the families
of those who get lost at sea.
It's a really, really harsh environment.
[water pouring]
It's a typical kind of scenario
where people will get into trouble.
There's something like 300 or 400
of those shipping containers
go into the sea every year,
and they just float
around near the surface.
So you're not going to
know, especially at night.
It makes total sense.
When things get wet with salt water,
as it evaporates, like it
would do in that climate,
it forms little salt crystals.
He's checking out his
communications equipment.
And by washing it off with fresh water,
that'll get rid of the salt crystals
that could stop them working.
He'll let it dry in the sun.
He's not using loads of water.
You can see he's being really careful
about measuring it out.
And that should make his
sat phone work again later.
And we can tell it's a sat
phone from the antenna.
If the repair works, albeit
a little bit Heath Robinson,
he can phone for help.
If you've been on a life
raft for even a few hours,
it gets uncomfortable.
If you've been in one for hours,
days, weeks, months, terrible.
And you get to your wit's end.
So, in this scene,
what Robert Redford's trying to do
is just generate a little light.
And it's difficult at night.
I mean, the moon's bright behind him.
And what you can do with a
mirror is reflect moonlight.
But it's difficult on water
because of all the waves,
the little ripples are reflecting.
So what Robert's trying to
do is make a small fire,
a contained fire in his raft.
Now, that is fraught with danger.
Typically, if people
run out of pyrotechnics,
they're gonna scream and shout.
But you can't be heard across open water.
But what he could have done is,
as well as packing some
pyrotechnical light devices,
pack a laser flare,
because they're brilliant.
This is not uncommon for
people to have to make
these really critical
life-death decisions.
And it's an all-or-nothing
thing, isn't it,
if it doesn't work.
There's an amazing anecdote
from Greenland in the war
where three American airmen
who were stranded on the coast
set fire to their warm
jackets in the winter,
knowing that if people saw
the fire, they'd get rescued,
and if they didn't,
they'd freeze to death.
In terms of realism for the scene
where Robert Redford makes a small fire,
accidentally sets fire to his whole raft,
realism, 9.
Lots and lots of life rafts and lifeboats
have got little manuals in them.
And this is one of the
sort of standard diagrams
that you'll see in it, like ocean currents
and where the water will take you.
I know it's all metaphor,
but would you be able to
trail behind a metal lifeboat
on a section of oars and life jackets?
Eh.
I mean, people have survived in worse.
But that is pretty clever, isn't it?
Triangles are one of the
strongest structures you can make.
It's minimizing the amount
of knots he's got to tie.
It's got a little bit of
give in it for the sea.
Pi: "Establish a strict
schedule for eating,
keeping watch, and getting rest."
Spot on. Getting a routine
is absolutely critical.
You can sense the passing of time
by watching the movement of the sun.
So if you put your arm out --
and this is the same for all of us,
'cause our hands and our arms
are about the right proportion --
that's 10 degrees, which
is just under an hour.
15 degrees is how much
the sun moves in an hour.
So you know that you've
got as many of those
as it is for the time of year
before sunrise and sunset.
So there are things you can
do to keep track of time.
Pi: "Do not drink urine or seawater."
Yes, never. Stop!
Right, everyone, are you hearing me?
It will actually make you die quicker,
because if you drink
anything that's salty,
it exacerbates the problem of dehydration.
Pi: "Above all, don't lose hope."
The first point, I should say,
being a proper survival geek,
is never cut into metal with your knife,
'cause it'll just blunten it.
But if you go to the Imperial War Museum,
not far from where we're filming this,
there's a boat in there from
the Anglo-Saxon we spoke about,
and it's got notches in the gunnel
for how long they survived at sea.
And you will lose track if you
haven't got some form of log.
And paper will get wrecked and ruined.
So, yeah, just keep a mental thread
of what's been happening.
It's a good 8 or a 9, I think.
Thanks for watching.
And if you enjoyed this,
why not click on the video above?